so with a heck of mine I've been talking
to you quarter I haven't been saying a
ton about me so I'm a Berkeley an MIT
grad and I've roamed through two careers
before I got here chemical engineering
and eecs with a mems specialization so
micro electromechanical systems I've
done a big company rd at chevron
research and then at HP labs and then
after the split into agilent labs and
for the last dozen years i've been in
the more entrepreneurial space you can
see here ice 911 research you'll hear a
lot about today that's my environmental
nonprofit Stanford Here I am you see you
see what I do here I'm associated with
Roger house MEMS group members and nems
group over in eecs formally and and
attend some of his group meetings and
help sometimes mentoring his and Beth
pruitt students but I'd say the most
time I spend here at Stanford is this
class these days this fourth time I'm
teaching it and then my day job what
actually is where I earned my living is
my engineering consulting firm small
tech consulting the successor really to
my solo practice that I've still kept
alive men's insight and over this last
dozen years I and my colleagues we've
consulted for over 40 companies we do a
lot of stuff design invention
prototyping strategy IP it's due
diligence it's it's actually a blast I
have a really great team and over the
years I've gotten a lot of patents
issued in various things and I've got a
bunch of patents pending so I love to
invent and I'm one of the entrepreneurs
will be talking about here but I wanted
to emphasize before going any further
you know people get up front and they
talk about I and me me me and it's
always always about the team who's
helping you you can't possibly do most
of what most of us try to do on your own
and so who's your team and I'm lucky
enough to have just on the technical
part we've got another couple
looks helping on the management side
giving me management advice because you
might have seen in that academic
credentials I don't have any formal
management training it's all but a job
but I've got of this team of I think 16
here and we're about to add one more
almost entirely PhDs and and the one
who's not a PhD is is one of my key
business advisors wow she's absolutely
phenomenal and we are a really
compatible crew and we just love working
together and I am just blessed it so
it's it's all about the team we're going
to jump through a few more things
through this class we're going to do a
quick review on what's the climate
situation you saw a bunch of this at the
beginning of the quarter with John kumi
and Terry root speaking and then we're
going to go into what the latest IPCC
assessment is looking like because
they're starting to release results and
then we'll talk about why you would
consider geoengineering we've talked
about many more straightforward
engineering approaches we're going to
get into geoengineering we're going to
get into my project which is not quite
engine not quite geoengineering and then
we'll do a little bit of a class wrap up
so this was one of John kameez charts
that he showed us and just as a takeaway
summary from this global co2
concentration is higher than at any time
in the past eight hundred thousand years
I think in his book he only had gone
back 400,000 so now he's doubled that
history and that's a big deal why is
that a big deal we'll talk about that
right here people have linked that
pretty unambiguous Lee to the
temperature rise that we're seeing and
in all of the models that people had
every time they look at it we find that
we're exceeding the most pessimistic
estimates that people had made this one
is courtesy of Ken caldera and in fact
several of the geoengineering slides and
this background are he he really takes a
serious look at geoengineering over time
and the the bad news is there's no
practical way and his view
to see emissions reduction to be able to
reduce temperatures this century so what
do we do and in fact a lot of the people
looking into geoengineering I saw a
beautifully reasonable questions from
you all on why would you do this or this
is the only hope what you know what what
Ken's point is and what my point when i
started my project was is is that you
want you want to have it studied so that
if your backs are to the wall someday
it's the option you really don't want to
have to use but if your backs are to the
wall you'll understand what the risks
and the benefits are so you're doing
your homework in advance to know are we
going to go there or not so the co2
emissions keep exceeding all these
scenarios that were estimated and what's
going on why does that raise temperature
it's changing the equilibrium set point
in the atmosphere you know as you're
absorbing radiation and your rear a da
ting out to space as you change the
chemical composition of the atmosphere
you've changed the set point where
that's going to equilibrate to after a
while as we keep increasing co2 or
methane you know other greenhouse gases
that set point with this given amount of
incoming radiation keeps rising and we
haven't equilibrated yet and so what
people are saying again from ken caldera
2008 paper with Matthews preventing
further warming would require near zero
emissions right now but we don't seem to
be doing that the IPCC fifth assessment
report they've just started publishing
parts of this in October the full thing
will be published coming in 2014 but
they've published the physical science
basis and I really enjoyed I don't know
if you call any of this enjoying in its
way but I found really informative going
through the summary for policymakers
easily available online you can see it
here IPCC data org and you can see the
assessment of you know what's been
happening with co2 what the summer sea
ice extent has been what the average
upper ocean heat content is what the
global average sea level changes this is
really careful work if you read this
these reports these are hundreds and
thousands of scientists depending which
working group you have going through it
appears to be semi infinite peer-review
to go through making sure that they are
presenting what is the most unbiased
data possible if anything the IPCC has
often been faulted for being a bit too
conservative because they want to be
sure not to let out conclusions that
strike anybody is alarmist what I found
most alarming because I you know we're
kind of familiar with what's been
happening was their projections for the
future depending on various scenarios
basically running around what kind of
co2 is going to be what sort of co2
level are we looking at for the rest of
this century and the global mean sea
level rise becomes really quite large I
mean it's already large enough to be
causing problems to coastal cities right
we all know that this is in meters and
this is by 2100 and it's really becoming
quite large in the worst case scenarios
and remember a couple slides ago we said
we always seem to be exceeding what what
the worst-case scenarios are saying so
we really have a problem here MIT years
ago put out this greenhouse gamble when
I started my work so I I started
worrying about this climate situation a
lot back in 2006 after seeing the Al
Gore Inconvenient Truth movie and at
that point the greenhouse gamble was
this wheel of fortune if you clicked on
it your chances were really good you
know more than fifty percent of ending
up at two and a half degrees C
temperature rise or less which is
alarming enough and this was live online
it may still be the last time I dared to
check in which was a couple years back
all of this has collapsed into this
teeny wedge here that is according to
the more recent estimates that MIT
policy and climate folks had made there
is a snow
less chance of us getting away with less
than three degrees C temperature rise
and the chances are really much much
worse our that will get to temperature
rises that are much much worse again why
do we care i'm pretty sure i've shown
you this chart before this was Terry
root taking with a graphic artist the
conclusions from the IPCC fourth
assessment report and saying well so if
we rise the degree c you know fine i get
more days at the beach right why is it a
problem well you have a number of really
horrific consequences from temperature
rise continuing and the ones that got my
attention were this extinction of most
of or many of the known species you know
up to close to half of the known species
because you know mass extinctions well
I'm not sure that's going to be good for
humans either and so what we have as a
conclusion here in the IPCC's latest
assessment report this fifth assessment
report I'll read this aloud cumulative
emissions of co2 largely determined
global mean surface warming by the late
twenty-first century and beyond most
aspects of climate change will persist
for many centuries even if emissions of
co2 are stopped as we've already got
enough inventory in the atmosphere we're
still equilibrate aset point this
represents a substantial multi-sensory
climate change commitment created by
past present and future emissions of co2
you can see why I was so fascinated by
professor Brent Constance lecture of the
way to sequester co2 in a way that looks
workable and even profitable which means
that it could go to scale this is this
is scary stuff and you know I I can't
bring myself to give you the scary stuff
without having a ray of hope to but it's
it's pretty scary so what's the bright
side well it's opportunity there are a
lot of things one can try to do
and personally I find it's a lot easier
to live with this by going all out to do
what I can and I find that a very
helpful way just for my own peace of
mind so what are our choices mitigation
adaptation and suffering on the climate
problems big urgent and misunderstood
which makes it great for starting
something new and Stanford one of the
more entrepreneurial universities around
and of course John's view is that you
have lots of entrepreneurs working on
lots of things trying things seeing what
we're seeing what fails and then you
know iterating to good solutions
business needs environmentalists and
environmentalists need business so the
reason I couldn't come to the class
where Dave Duff was speaking is because
I was at the cleantech open which talked
about a hotbed of meeting other
entrepreneurs who are attempting to do
something in the climate space this was
a fairly amazing this was a very amazing
experience and because ice 911 got to be
a semi-finalist which in itself is
amazing we're the one nonprofit who's
ever been accepted to do that we got to
go through six months of very intense
mentoring and here were the grand
winners powwow energy and you know there
were just a lot of people participating
in this they made sure everybody who
participated one in new connections and
new mentoring Rex Northern he spoken in
this class before actually in past
quarters you could probably see it
online on YouTube if you wanted to and
the winner and I believe that's Eric
Steve and who helped run things on the
western region really neat really neat
and the proud CEO of powwow energy and
the grand prize winner came from five
category finalists and I wanted to just
show you the diversity of things that
people are working on air water waste
polymer green these were nice people
they they have they are off and running
all ready to deal with landfill waste
plastic in a really nice way here and in
China energy generation Helion energy
talk about diversity these folks are
working on fusion energy in a safe way
Green Building bioadhesive Alliance
starting from yes the most humble thing
you can think of swine manure what are
you doing something really useful h j3
composite technologies these guys are
using i believe these are the ones who
are using carbon nanotubes to build a
material with which they can reinforce
aging infrastructure and prevent people
needing new well Ollie cost of
demolishing things and new cement and
then powwow energy these guys what they
really come down to is realizing that
energy is water water is energy and they
have a nice IT play of finding leaks and
really helping farmers agriculturalists
well and the sustainability award winner
this was beautiful indoor hydroponic
farms and if I am correct in my memory
here in an indoor farm you'd have a
light source you'd have something
growing okay great in their case they
decided to make it cylindrical so the
light source runs down the middle think
of it like a filament and they're
rotating their crop around it so they
just get much more yield per space so
what I want to leave you with is people
are innovating like mad trying to help
the climate situation and there's more
you know there were a hundred twenty
exhibitors which included semi-finalists
like us Ice 911 and alumni in many
different categories I forget if it was
six or eight different categories all
working hard on ways to try to improve
the dreadful situation I just showed you
and of course I always keep in mind i
showed you this at the beginning of the
quarter too simple can be best right
this is as simple as bringing light to
basically steel structures bait and weld
metal structures you know by poking a
hole in the roof and putting a bottle
filled with water and a little bit of
bleach into it and sealing it up right
and suddenly when it's daytime outside
you've got light inside your home rather
than a windowless weather than a
windowless place where you don't really
want to be
doors much simple simple solutions so
moving on from entrepreneurship is alive
and well and thriving in this space
let's talk about mitigation adaptation
and geoengineering so mitigation is
everything about the cleantech open that
we've just looked at and so much more
conservation energy efficiency
renewables most of what we've seen the
lecturers talked about this quarter in
our class and this is all needed but it
may be too slow to prevent major harms
it takes a long time to rebuild an
infrastructure if you have a better
solar technology it takes a while to get
it installed built and installed in the
meantime sea levels are rising we we
have you know difficulties in coastal
cities for sure and cities plan around
it and if you fast forward at least
where I decided to look at is are there
any band aid measures that could buy us
some time while we're doing all the
things that we should do here in
mitigation and adaptation possible
emergency backup if all else fails
remember that moral hazard which a lot
of you and your questions worried about
well if it's that simple why don't we
just keep on spewing out you know as
much pollution as we want because some
magic fix is going to take care of it
isn't that pretty responsible pretty
irresponsible yes and it's actually why
I kept my own project pretty darn quiet
for a long time well I'm not sure I want
anybody to know about it until we really
need it because you don't want it to be
used as an excuse but you might really
need it and so doing our homework
upfront is what people are doing and it
involves such complex issues you really
have to be careful you sure don't want
the unintended consequences this Terry
route was really eloquent about you know
just introducing one species in an area
to take care of another one endless
endless other consequences that you
haven't thought about and that always is
an issue in anything you do especially
if you're thinking about doing it on a
massive global scale could it be
irreversible that's a worry and are the
climate models good enough to figure out
what you're doing who decides if you can
do it
who decides that they want it in their
own backyard right these are all complex
issues here's a ken caldera slide saying
okay if i were to stabilize climate here
are some ways I want to do things we
could control long wave radiation by
diminishing the energy demand producing
clean energy remove things like co2 or
we could control shortwave radiation ie
we could reduce the amount of solar
radiation absorb those are that's one
way to look at what we're doing and
here's another way to look at the
Earth's energy balance and it's you know
it's interesting you've got the incoming
solar radiation your reflected by clouds
your reflected by surface we've got this
whole water evaporation cycle going on
and then you've got the long-wave
radiation happening where the greenhouse
gases are at play here it's complicated
so the two distinct geoengineering
strategies then this is from the Royal
Society geoengineering report because
people worldwide are worrying about
stuff like this right you can find
things published carbon dioxide removal
techniques okay there's some problems it
seems with most of them again professor
Brent Constance's one looks like maybe a
way that some of this can be taken care
of or their solar radiation management
techniques and that's that can have a
very quick response but it doesn't get
at the root problem there are articles
published that have all kinds of pretty
pictures about many different ways
people can think about doing
geoengineering and one that has gotten a
lot of attention is this one of adding
particulates stratospheric sulfate
aerosol injection like volcanoes with
the observation that after a volcanic
eruption temperatures seem to be reduced
so this again is a ken caldera slides
and in his case and a lot of people tend
to conflate geoengineering with
stratospheric sulfate aerosol injection
it's the one that they're talking about
when they say to you engineering and
people I've been in a meeting about a
year and a half ago where an airlock
airplane companies many
factors were coming in to say how they
could get this to the stratosphere
cheaply you know less than a billion
dollars oh boy personally this worries
me because I'm not sure our models are
good enough to understand what happens
with us but I do understand the the
claim that one must do one's homework
first to figure this out and people are
concluding some of them that this
reflection of sunlight could offset some
climate change a lot of the time so
again this is ken kalderon and when he's
saying turning on geoengineering he's
talking about stratospheric sulfate
aerosol injection it looks like a
bailout you know if you turn it on you
can lower your temperature pretty
quickly depending when you're doing it
great what's wrong with this well one
thing is that if you stop your
temperatures tend to pop back up perhaps
to a lower curve now that they're going
to asymptotically approach but they're
going to pop up quicker than they were
rising in the first place and that means
enormous pressure on species again an
enormous really quick climate changes
they also are and so this means that
your species extinctions and such may be
worse off by starting something like
this and then stopping it which is which
is a problem meaning you start you may
be committed for the long haul the other
thing that people talk about on this is
that they're beginning to conclude now
from the models that this will increase
the severity of mid latitude storms that
is all these horrific typhoons and such
we may get more of them if we do it it
changes rainfall patterns quite a lot so
it's got risks and it's got risks on the
whole earth but you can understand why
people are looking at it I took a
different approach and coming as an
engineer into climate back there you
know when I started this in 2006 I was
looking for climate people to give me
some feedback of did this make any sense
at all and I keep being told that it
does Armand coin is the executive
director of it called a clean air task
force back in Boston
and they he's been very kind about this
I mean this is his considered opinion
you can get the full quote on our
website but no question in his mind that
this is one of the half dozen or so most
important research projects underway
globally on mitigating climate change
you know that kind of feedback keeps you
going why why am I looking at ice and
notice of course satish who was here
lecturing we've known each other for a
long time on this and shalini
venkatesh's person I've been working
with for years in small tech consulting
so and new back at HP Labs so when
gathers terrific people along the way if
you're really lucky why am I looking at
I smell why is it ice 911 and it's one
of the problems is that the melt is
accelerated far faster than those 2007
IPCC predictions these were the
predictions IPCC this was the whole
range from that fourth assessment report
and what actually happened in two
thousand seven and then 2012 were these
spectacularly large ice melts everybody
knew it was a positive feedback loop and
it you know this was going to be
accelerating but nobody knew it was
going to go that fast and chasing ice if
you haven't seen it I think it's out now
that you can get a DVD on it I've seen
it twice with really great expert panels
discussing it afterwards right after it
came out phenomenal film about how
quickly the ice is disappearing in the
world so to go back to the video that we
were showing I'll show you just three
shots from that we're looking down on
the Arctic it's same month each time
june nineteen eighty this is from age of
sea ice by rigor and wallace so that's
where you can look it up who is asking
june nineteen eighty lots of bright
reflective ice some open ocean some thin
you know first your eyes a little bit of
second-year eyes you know not very
reflective very reflective now 20 years
later not much multi-year ice left last
year not much at all where you can see
little artifacts here's where i was
trying to
block out all the satellite buoy you
know diamonds and such I was told this
was a little confusing but it really is
darker here there isn't much there what
does that mean what are the effects one
of the effects that we're having more
severe storms from the temperature
changes and the rainfall distribution
changes that are coming from the ice
melt and the horrible typhoon that we
recently had with real human costs you
know people talk about numbers but there
are human beings there who wow what a
situation there are of course great
opportunities for graphic artists yeah
this is this is from I believe this is a
photo composite of the times square new
york city subway system with a scuba
diver in there but you know not as far
from reality as you might think and
there are these estimates many many
really credible outfits are now running
estimates scenarios of what is it going
to cost to shore up infrastructure
against sea level rise and severe storms
over time and I've been advised from the
cleantech open to only show a few data
points at a time so New York City okay
two billion dollars per year now to
shore up their infrastructure China 1
jul 13 billion per year to shore it up
it's just it's a worldwide problem many
many of these in Europe as well and
these are just some estimates you know
at San Francisco Bay Area certainly
we've got our issues too right and it
isn't just you know some other places
than ours so many of us live in states
where we've got a saltwater coastline
we're in a coastal County it's a big big
deal and the predictions are that after
we get to 2050 sea levels will have
risen enough we're not talking billions
a year anymore but we're talking
trillions so of course we've talked
about no mitigation we've talked about
adaptation right here and we've talked a
little bit about geoengineering of
course there's doing nothing
but this doesn't seem really good when I
say methane I mean the methane releases
from permafrost melt from the Arctic
Ocean melt it's a not a good scenario so
to summarize again these options
mitigation it is the long-term solution
it just it looks too slow adaptation
really expensive geoengineering some of
them look interesting you know I I kind
of like this saltwater missed one that
is helping to nucleate new clouds to try
to reflect more sunlight at that level
because it's reversible right if you
stop it and things should settle down
again some seem really risky how do you
get back trillions of orbiting lenses
that you launch up and what's the co2
cost to do it that the engineering the
atmosphere it bothers me but you know
our backs may be driven to the wall I
took a different approach what I decided
to do was look into as i call it
rebuilding the Earth's refrigerator by
using artificial reflective ice then
working on this since 2006 and we can
address many areas coastal areas
glaciers snow permafrost some of you are
concerned rightly so about how on earth
are you going to deploy its scale how on
earth will this not be causing
additional problems what we'll talk
about that but those are the right some
of the right questions what are we
looking at then back to that energy
balance we're looking at modifying the
surface reflection here and we're
looking at not suppressing evaporation
which i think is really important people
you know what years ago we're thinking
about why do we cover the Arctic in a
plastic sheet well for one thing you
would be rebuilding your pool cover
because if you're suppressing
evaporation suppressing evaporative
cooling you actually warm things up and
I've done many tests and little tanks
sitting here in this area in the
sunlight sunny afternoons to find that
you can have something like 13 degrees
Fahrenheit small tank you can have 13
degrees higher
under a white plastic sheet than in open
water it's it's really effective but
it's not it's not going to make things
cooler so you want to be able to allow
some evaporative cooling to go on and
I'm pretty sure about that and you want
to not mess up you know getting your
back radiation back out my contention is
one of the ground rules on trying to
engineer climate at all is that you want
something that's going to be localized
enough that you could if you found you
know here's let's call this uncontrolled
temperature rise or uncontrolled co2
rise let's let's say that we put
something out there and it was
phenomenally effective in fact it was so
effective we drove ourselves to the next
ice age not such a good outcome so my
contention is that whatever we put out
there we'd better be able to undo and we
have to make sure that we're not going
to crunch you know you think the Arctic
what's going on up there it's called
nothing's alive oh no it's it's one of
the basis of the world's food chain so
you really have to make sure somebody
else was asking I mean I loved your
questions somebody else was asking well
gee what's going to happen to all your
sea organisms if you go and carpet
something with some material it's the
right question you have to make sure i
believe to keep things as close to the
natural process as possible my whole I
thought is bootstrap the natural process
you could stop anytime you want you
won't bounce back you it's you know as
in stopping the stratospheric sulfate
aerosol injections just keep it gentle
and so I've had because this has been
run on seven years of volunteer work
I've also had the luxury if you will
since it's not the day job and I don't
have an academic reputation riding on it
you know it's not I don't have some boss
telling me you've got to do it this way
to just sit there and make the ground
rules for myself there's there's a joy
and a lack of funding in that way if you
fill and the ground rules I've come up
with I I think are good ones fast to
implement sustainable and it
don't be belting up more co2 making this
stuff then you're going to be
compensating for ecologically respectful
boy that's been number one in this seven
years search for materials reversible
while I'm not sure that we're going to
be able to pull this back if we manage
to freeze this into ice I'm not sure we
can pull it back out but we can make it
biodegradable or we can say hey we're
awfully good at suit we could always
gather some suit around where needed and
you got to make it safe and you've got
these pieces of these two glasses
sitting out here this is regular ice
right here and this is our special stuff
where we've made it brighter you can see
it's brighter and because it's that safe
don't worry you won't have to follow me
to the hospital later it true that's if
I've done this before and I think that's
final we're very excited that we finally
found the right material where you can
do that so what have we been doing what
we've been working hard of the seven
years the first one really was thinking
and figuring out what needed to be done
and then six years of lab and field
tests have been really critical to
development there's sati chigan you'll
recognize him as one of your speakers
yep you can if you want drink it if
you're dare here is Tony who's pond
we've been working on this year we are
so happy with that and here's his friend
Doug who who helped make our connection
again there I am with pardon me my cal
hat we worked before in the Sierra
Nevada mountains for several years up on
people's drinking water this was nice
the sierra lakes County Water District
was permitting us to work there because
we told him exactly what our materials
were and those those were things like
the hollow glass spheres that I was very
in favor of for quite a while which are
basically floating sand but the problem
is you're going to be working on
somebody's drinking water you've got a
fence all this in so you can get it off
later no adverse effects in the water
but you're really
just don't want to clog up any filters
or anything so we worked for years on
that and now we're in this test pond
laboratory in Minnesota this is Tony's
pond so the person from two pictures ago
where he dug this pond when he built his
house 15 years ago and he's a retired
PhD chemist recently retired and he is
delighted so wonderful to go out there
and work on this and help us with our
experiments and he's he's just awesome
what that guy knows it's wonderful and
so we got to test unfenced materials to
catch the melt last March in April and
Satish came up now this is probably the
third iteration of our buoy and sensor
platform this is all Satish 'as work and
its really pretty neat and we've just
put that out here we were out there two
three weeks ago to put in the latest set
of instrumentation and materials to
catch the freeze so this is worth the
plane trip to have collaborators like
that and yes after TSA showed Satish the
love as he was trying to get this on the
plane there were a couple days of
reassembling the buoy oh but there we
are and this is Tony's basement and it's
really a pretty great way to work and do
this and we got to build these giant
plastic cubes we found the pond is small
enough that if you have different test
areas they kind of communicate with each
other if you're trying to test materials
nearby each other so this is trying to
cut down some cross flow it won't be
perfect thermal isolation but this
surrounding the buoy now out in the
middle of the pond we got it in just
just before the freeze allows us to put
different materials in here and start
testing them and so for the March April
we don't have results from this last
deployment that was just a couple weeks
ago yet but in March April when we were
catching the melt we found that floating
glass spheres so basically hollow sand
lots of people make very tiny hollow
glass spheres very bright and they use
them in paints and thinners they're
really good for a number of things and
we found that they were you know using
our little albedo meters handheld solar
radiation
meteors meters brighter than the
surrounding ice so we could slow down
the melt and we could see that we use
sheets I use sheets a lot about three
winters ago it's miserable sheets equals
sales you have any wind at all you have
problems you're just up there
continually trying to reactor them that
lake up in the Sierras we were doing
that a lot but they're so effective and
this happens to be a sheet of it's a
porous sheet it's not just plastic it's
a very porous one has a high content of
silica actually like the floating glass
did nice and effective but even a teeny
sheet like this you know we're chasing
it around this pond mostly Tony chasing
it around biodegradable materials very
nice in fact I think biodegradable
materials or something safe enough to
drink is really a really promising way
to go and that instrumentation I'm just
happy with what Satish has come up with
he's got a plan now to make something
even even lighter and smaller the ice
additives we just had this breakthrough
a couple months ago and I could hardly
contain myself I finally went and tried
the simplest possible option I will not
say it out here sorry I don't want this
out on youtube but it's the simplest
safest thing and it's and why don't I
want it out on youtube you'll see in a
couple minutes certainly anybody who's a
pond we're experimenting on needs to
know and we'll give them full disclosure
certainly we're being very above board
on this but we also think that we could
maybe start up finally some profitable
businesses from something like this and
that might give us the funding we need
to help this work get out to the Arctic
so while we filed some initial IP where
we also need to publish our paper on
this we're just not saying this too
loudly yet what it is but it's really
safe and it was such a simple thing
finally after seven years of looking at
various materials to find something this
simple but it's profound it freezes
faster it last longer in the Sun and
remember
the ice experts tell me don para vich in
particular dr. Don paravaci New
Hampshire that if you can extend the
melting season just a couple weeks or if
you can start it a couple weeks sooner
it you know either end of the summer
here extend a little farther into the
summer start it a little sooner into the
fall winter you can make a profound
difference in how quickly that ice
disappearance is happening and you can
maybe fend off at this point the
estimates are thirty five percent of
temperature rises from this loss of the
Earth's refrigerator up in the Arctic so
you could really slow down some of these
effects a lot and I must say the world
is getting kind to experimenters on a
low budget now you can get a merciful
temperature sensors for not much now and
so I put them in these buckets that you
see in the photo there these nice little
immersive all temperature sensors and
let them go through the ride in a
freezer you can let them freeze up like
this and then you can let them melt so
regular ice and the safe additive just
like what's in the glasses that you have
there and you can watch the the slower
melt we should be back on the chart
please thanks you can watch the slower
melt with the additive versus with with
just plain old ice so it's freezing
faster its lasting longer this is really
really interesting and this is by far
the lowest cost material that I've been
looking at yet this is actually one to
two orders of magnitude lower than the
cost that of anything else I've been
looking at including you know my old
favorite the hollow glass spheres why
fifty thousand square kilometers that
was the historic summer to summer ice
melt in the 90s and so this is a very
thin layer of Bryce bright ice that I'm
costing but it's comparable to what i
was thinking with the hollow glass
spheres 35 million that becomes doable
right I mean any sizable philanthropist
could do that now that of course is just
the material costs for the additive that
isn't making or transporting the ice
there and getting it deployed i granted
that but at least the
material cost is is low we're lucky that
we've got a world-class team you know
you know me now you've certainly heard
satish talk Shalini is flickering and
we've had this governing board and
advisors if you've checked out the ice
911 website maybe you've seen some of
these names you know including Terry
route one of the Nobel Prize Co
recipients you know just phenomenal
people and then through the cleantech
open we got a whole new set of mentors
helping us kimberly is now helping us
you remember Kimberly's great workshop
she's now helping us a lot David rumbler
was auditing the class for a while you
might have noticed him coming in really
nice we're still pending on our 501 C 3
but we're at least getting responses now
that are telling us the process is
moving along we were approved in
California quite a while ago that we're
just waiting for the federal approval
but how the heck do you fund something
like this you know this has been one of
the ongoing dilemmas I'll say that at
this point we've gotten this far on a
little under two hundred thousand
dollars of donations primarily from my
neighbors my friends and neighbors who
know that I do what I say I'll do I
volunteered in the schools a lot when my
kids were well we're still in them over
the years and people who know me that
way have said okay I hear what she's
doing I like what she's doing I know
she'll do what she says I'll donate but
my goodness you know grants have been
tricky because geoengineering this falls
under that label though Steve Schneider
the late Steve Schneider labeled an eco
engineering I've been to a workshop on
soft geoengineering you know there's all
kinds of labels too but it still gets
lumped in with geoengineering and some
of those options scare some people write
some of those options scare me and so
that's made grants slow to get but
things I think are changing as the
situation gets worse you know when I
started this this was the option I hoped
we'd never need it was the backup option
of you know let's hope will never need
it but it's looking more and more
important and I think the world is
changing so that the grants may be able
to
we're going to try crowdfunding and I
think we're going to try crowdsourcing a
game I think I'm tired of sitting here
we're gonna and our game is going to be
dice 911 your playing dice with the
climate with little stickers the ice 911
logo sitting on the six side and going
there and I think that will be our
giveaway for our crowdfunding you can go
through and people are funding climate
projects this way I just read about some
individual lakes in Ontario that have
been used for looking at acidification
water acidification that were kept alive
through some crowdfunding efforts really
interesting accelerators like the clean
tech open that's not the only one but
it's a great one sponsorships and
partnerships with industry with academia
and then profitable subsidiaries are the
ways that we know to look at funding and
deployment and we're going after it
because we've got the right material now
and the situation is getting worse and
so all of this is trying to generate the
dollars so we can do the rd to be able
to deploy at scale in the Arctic are we
trying to cover the whole Arctic heavens
no if we can pick critical areas on
glacial melt ponds around the coast of
Greenland maybe in hudson bay maybe off
the coast of Alaska critical areas and
start there that's the way to do it you
don't want to try to have to carpet the
entire Arctic donors we've had these
were 28 I think different families who
supported the work overtime and that's
how we've gotten this no salaries but
the instrumentation and travel but
here's the development plan developed
with the aid of what we've learned at
the cleantech open all these public uses
we've been looking at glacial melt ponds
permafrost snow sea ice but then
commercial uses too because when you
know how to cool things you know the
world needs cooling too so we're looking
into that and that's why I'm being quiet
about specifically what this marvelous
whiter ice is about what do we need from
here
about two and a half million we're
thinking over the next couple years to
really get this out there deploying
Greenland somebody asked what are we
trying to deploy we're trying to look at
a glacial melt pond and we're timing it
why April why April 23 to 26 Doug stout
who was here at the beginning of the
quarter lecturing on his Arctic than
Antarctica explorations is running a ski
tour and an ultramarathon in Greenland
at that point and he is so tied in with
the community there because this is not
his first time there that he is going to
they've agreed from his asking to help
us make some deployments there it's a
nice way to get in there so this is one
of the slides I showed at the cleantech
open is where I was finishing off a talk
and again more graphic art is fun but
the concerns are rail right here's a
disappearing New York City as sea level
rises it's very costly though graphic
art fun or not it's very costly we've
got a solution here it looks like we
could even make some profitable
sustainable companies which is probably
their the right way to get it to scale
and we're working now Minnesota
California heading to Greenland should
we get the funding and that's that's the
end of the ice 911 story for now but
it's an exciting one and if you're
interested in staying informed send me
an email and i will put you on our
distribution list for updates and things